[Music]
it's that type of night [ __ ]
it's that type of night [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
let me get that lighter though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cops are outside we don't give a [ __ ]
jack in Stan Liddy you drooled on
yourself like a [ __ ] [ __ ] smoke
that weed please I did you took one
little half a bag [ __ ] it like the
Indian love movie it finally talked me
into smoking mushrooms like the Indians
look at the shape of this part we will
look there
[Music]
uncle Joey here post-church although I
shut the lights
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] these mushrooms a kick
of him
I can't hear I'm hearing sirens who
gives a [ __ ] I got the Prince of
Darkness [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you do with
your life
what'd you do all day tonight nothing
will be mushrooms go ruling biscuits do
a podcast drinking water eating nicotine
gum you have no [ __ ] idea what my
mind is that right now the prison I love
you [ __ ] we got tons of reefer
mushrooms and nut by hot balls
if you're in the neighborhood drop in
between telling you where we are that's
how we do it
we ain't telling you dick all [ __ ] I'm
about to turn the lights off completely
in this [ __ ]
mushroom almost done
what Morelos that was good for
circulation
are you [ __ ] kidding me a signet on
what am i doing I don't know I have no
idea
start with that motherfucker's below we
sold your soul for rock-and-roll [ __ ]
Roberto Clemente on my shirt
who's gonna [ __ ] stop me we the
mushrooms
like a [ __ ] at this point where does the
mushroom loose in here all that giggle
I said you should be doing
[Music]
where can you run to what more can you
do
no more tomorrow life is killing you
dreams turned to night miss heaven turns
to hell mass of confusion nothing more
to tell hey goob Watterson miss Alicia
backwards why you think I'm still here
take it I don't give a [ __ ] with the
album play black with history that's
next
play the mushrooms smoked a mushroom was
down backwards swing a half satanic
messages [ __ ]
[Music]
what's it coming - what's it coming till
he saying
you eat mushrooms are available
chocolate Sabbath bloody Sabbath that's
what's [ __ ] happy understand it
toughen it up you suck it up and you're
[ __ ] live another day
what do you have to be like these
women's groups and planters [ __ ] all the
time
every time I say a fat joke I had some
[ __ ] and Chiquita milkshakes saying I
can't say that I don't give a [ __ ] no
more my stomach gets dizzy that's good
luck let me something my stomach gets
itchy from time to time that meat pizzas
coming pizzas coming [ __ ] I don't
know from where it's coming from
somewhere I'm saying
Fergie we're gonna be a speck of a ball
gonna sit there and stare at me and give
me the [ __ ] balloon guy I spoke of a
boat together twelve eleven o'clock one
o'clock we here at maybe you're an
Australian there's a 20 lb shred that
[ __ ] guitar the understanding I love
blacks at the most blacks out that would
be it
I probably listen to the go-go's getting
[ __ ] in the air somewhere an alley
[Music]
what do you want you'll be a look and
try to fight my neck no leave the scene
nothing you need to see that that's all
you need to do is smoke the ball of life
that's why I suggest you to smoke a bowl
loosen up you're worried about drop ever
lose a [ __ ] in a week you still never
gonna work every [ __ ] day slick
groceries Bernice and this is a hundred
I like this old Jew he hangs out with
black beef you gotta watch those Jews
then I go with black people a little
[ __ ] little [ __ ] kumquats [ __ ]
sneak up on Farah Khan's you think I'd
be the place - hi
so tell me people
[Music]
it's a and say hey tell me people am I
going in say hey the [ __ ] spark him if
you gotta don't just sit there staring
at me like I owe you ten bucks
it's time to smoke one of these [ __ ]
mushrooms to show you how it's done is
shooting home I haven't smoked a
mushroom since 83 with the gardulla
brothers on Westside Avenue look at this
[ __ ] media
[Music]
this shit's killing [ __ ] I let
it dry in the car today like the savage
that I am oh my god we've been Sam oh it
was a nicotine gum after the [ __ ] he's
got a cat hair on it yeah you eat [ __ ]
you don't find the [ __ ] hair from
here and then every once in a while you
find the hairiest suit eat that [ __ ]
thing its nourishment stop crying your
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't wonder your throat
hurts me you suck some lady's [ __ ]
vagina I got a sore throat from a [ __ ]
what does that [ __ ] I ain't [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] what's up there
[ __ ] look left over here lingering
over here like a don't fight me the
necklace I what's up you bad
[ __ ] Monday night late we're
here doing our thing just trying to
[ __ ] get it together get a notebook
and some right think about your religion
I don't know I'm not the type
[Music]
don't get no better than this
Tommy he's the way you act [ __ ]
clear way you act Lady Jaye hokey spooky
way to [ __ ] you hat
oh you people put some spooky music
carefully
[Music]
put the [ __ ] voices people laughing
Philippe
[Music]
[ __ ] this Laguna sunrise [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
the king of songs right here is
snowblind the anthem to some savages
even if I don't do blow I still list the
snow blind and salute that [ __ ]
because the lyrics are phenomenal
Dooly get ugly [ __ ]
he goes
[Music]
can't get us the decision oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I think those within my brain
[Music]
you say I'll live with you say I'll live
with every day [ __ ]
something going in my head oh [ __ ] with
the vices so spread say to me my very
soul makes me happy makes me call that
could be you about I'm gonna do a raffle
you can win an all-expense-paid trip to
come out here and sit with Lee and eat
mushrooms all week and sniff his feet
whatever the [ __ ] you're into how's that
looking for you [ __ ] see them
saying I'm trippin you're trippin your
family is strapped a pair on [ __ ]
I know you got some mushrooms and
grandmas [ __ ] medicine cabinet
my eyes are blind but I can see oh [ __ ]
[Music]
the snowflakes been on the tree going
one more question of this time lady
ready for this is the mushroom of debt
in the last basement
we think Lee
[Music]
late night periscope will you
[ __ ] I hope you're well I hope
you're healthy you have to go to work
tomorrow but we got to go to work
tomorrow that's all up to you I don't
know what grandma has my medicine
cabinet got to be creative you gotta
make some more medicine with Spike it as
a Sun Shade
[Music]
we gotta check on her moved on in times
look at him he's going deep my head oh
[ __ ]
here we go lisa is going on we take of
this [ __ ] home right now
if you don't have this on this is
originally on volume form but it's on
the greatest hits we sold our soul too
much let me feel the frost of dawn are
you [ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me
soon I'll feel the chilling glow too
much it's too much this guy was deep in
a [ __ ] bag when he wrote this [ __ ]
how do I know cuz I've been deep in a
bag I can't write thick some people have
different talents hit me they'll kick
this [ __ ] the only
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he just sit there don't you
think I know what I'm doing you telling
me doing it wrong
who the [ __ ] are you really the loser
this is what I feel I belong
[Music]
we'll be back on surface for a spokes of
muscles
you can back to you [ __ ] I
suggest you do the same we're going deep
into the murky waters of the underworld
tonight
[Music]